[Music]
in europe
and around the world the coronavirus
pandemic has caused
unprecedented economic challenges
but as more europeans get vaccinated
and restrictions are lifted growth is
expected to bounce back
it should be fueled by private
consumption
recovering investment and stronger
demands for european
exports national support schemes
backed by the eu have helped to prevent
a surge in joblessness
although the increase in female and
youth unemployment has been more marked
while hiring activity looks subdued in
the near term
stronger economic growth should help
unemployment fall back towards
pre-crisis level inflation
rose early this year due to some
temporary factors notably energy prices
but the underlying trend remains low
and is forecast to be broadly stable
governments across the eu have had to
increase their borrowing
to finance public support for the
economy
this has caused deficits to rise
above 3 percent of gdp in almost
all member states depth levels
have also risen to over 100 percent of
gdp
in the euro area we are expected to
start decreasing again
in 2022
our economic recovery is closely linked
to our recovery from the pandemic
and while we don't know what long-term
scars covet
may leave on the economy we do know
that the eu countries are set to receive
a major boost
from next generation eu which will
increase
as more funds are invested
[Music]
the strength and the pace of the
recovery
will differ across the eu but our new
common policies
will prepare us for the economic and
social challenges of the future
building a more competitive green
and digital europe
[Music]
you